today we're gonna be looking at SCP 343
object class safe special containment
procedures SCP 343 resides in a 6.1 by 6
point 1 meter room at minimal security
site 17 it should be brought any items
at requests and visited by at least one
staff member each day attempts to add
further safety precautions or required
clearances are unnecessary and
impossible due to the nature of a CP 343
description SCP 343 is a male seemingly
raceless humanoid and appearance with
apparent omnipotence SCP 343 was
discovered walking the streets of prague
and detained after a member of staff
witnessed him disappear from the streets
and reappear on a rooftop SCP 343 is
detained willingly in his chamber as
containment has proved impossible
addendum 343 - one SCP 343 colloquially
named god by the staff here looks like
an older man although his features are
different - each observer in my first
talk with him he claimed to be the
creator of the universe when i asked him
to prove this he laughed walk through
the wall of the chamber and returned
seconds later with a hamburger in his
hand when I returned for a second visit
the previously bare cell had been
furnished in an upscale Old English
style complete with a roaring fireplace
and seemed many times larger than it did
from the exterior SCP 343 greatly enjoys
speaking with people and seems to have a
knowledge of all topics visiting with
SCP 343 has become a daily event for
many of the staff here and all employees
report feeling generally happier after
visit attempts to bar staff below level
three clearance have proven unsuccessful
as guards assigned to watch the room
quit their posts saying you know he
likes company or shrugging when
questioned since s CB 343 has thus far
been harmless all staff have been
allowed access and somehow they all have
time to meet with them for as long as
they need for now I leave this report
open as further questioning of SCP 343
is ongoing dr. Beck addendum 343 - - in
regards to document 343 1a there are no
relevant records available or seemingly
in existence and similarly all records
of DOC ever working with a CP 343 or dr.
Beck are missing and presumed
non-existent all staff questioned about
the document convey ignorance of
document 343 - 1a and claimed not to
have met dr. in a related matter senior
officer dr. Beck has requested a hire
staff rotation quote to increase morale
in worse-off sections
end quote this was a very odd request
and was the subject of further
investigation other localized anomalies
such as better health greater job
satisfaction and lower fatalities in
this section have led to the request
being granted this subject is now closed
on orders of all flight
[Music]
addendum 343 - three data recovered on
from routine check of doctor network
drive document number 343 - 1a data lost
as of data expunged visitors of SCP 343
are to be questioned as to their intent
and converse data lost since pertaining
to the other SCP are to be put forth
data lost orders of dr. document 343 -
1b data lost apparently my orders have
gone missing this is the last straw
doctor about data lost all my reports
and requests to higher-ups have gone
unnoticed I will confront SCP 343
tomorrow signed dr.
you